this is a production of cornell
university
every fall students in cornell
university's restoration ecology course
take on a real world project in the
local community
working together to gather data analyze
the issues and report their findings
in 2011 the students examined plans to
dredge cayuga inlet where it's estimated
that more than six hundred thousand
cubic yards of sediment have accumulated
in the flood control channel at the
southern end of cayuga lake
this is what that segment would look
like piled at the university's shulkoff
field
the central issue according to course
instructor dr thomas whitlow is what to
do with the sediment after it's dredged
whitlow says the farther you move it the
more expensive it gets but from the
perspective of restoration ecology we're
not viewing the sediment as a waste
product we're treating it as a resource
that can be used to maintain or improve
ecosystem services locally
on december 1 2011
whitlow's class presented their findings
at a public meeting sponsored by the
tompkins county environmental management
council at the tompkins county public
library
we joined the management council's brian
eden during his introduction and
exchange ideas and i'm sure we'll be
better for it in the end because
i've been involved with a few other
programs that brought students and and
downtown folks together and they've been
highly productive
so
you know if you surveyed people in the
community what the priorities for a cuba
inlet would be they would suggest
navigation for recreational boating
flooding prevention waterfront
development
tourism competitive rowing ecosystem
enhancements would be far down the list
if they were on the list at all and i'm
happy to see a lot of folks here because
i know there are people in the community
that are interested in that and
hopefully we can use that energy to
maybe do something uh positive in the
future
as you can see uh from the maps and
the photos that we have 200 years of
general downward trends in the ecosystem
in the
cuga inlet and
the only way to really reverse that is
not to have a freestanding
funding for for ecosystem enhancements
they have to be combined with the
dredging program it has to be integrated
on a regular basis otherwise we won't be
able to
to really be able to change this this
trend that's been going on for such a
long period of time
so
uh you know a number of emc folks
got together this summer we've been
talking about these issues everyone
knows that we've been losing a lot of
wetlands in the vicinity a lot of
you know build out development in the
elmer road area
you know they're talking about
increased development on inlet island
there's a lot of economic pressure on
the city to generate uh income and
increase the tax base so that's that's
understandable but these all come with
costs to the ecosystem so anyway we met
with tom
tom whitlow and
and we did some walking around the inlet
and southwest uh park
and uh you know and and he thought maybe
there was something there that would
interest his students in his fall uh
ecology class so uh you know he's gone
ahead and i'm really uh interested in
seeing what what has been generated from
all this energy and so anyway tom uh is
tom whitlow is an associate professor of
horticulture and he's a plant ecologist
and he has a fall restoration ecology
class and
and uh let's get on with the show
thanks very much
hey
good okay
so i'm as excited as brian is to see
what the class is going to present
tonight this is uh
an an engine that once you start it it
takes on a life of its own
and
i always look back at the the class from
1999
and early on every fall semester i think
oh geez this class isn't halfway as good
as the class from 99 was
but
every year the classes have always
managed to eclipse that performance so
thank you all for coming tonight i
encourage you all to go over to the
state theater after this you can have
two hours to make comments after we get
out at nine o'clock
so please head over there and
hold your questions until the end but do
we will have a question and answer
period at the end so
i'll turn this over to ben headstrong
thanks for coming it's very encouraging
to see a full room i see they've been
sending the overflow over from the
fracking event like we asked so i
appreciate you stepping over
i speak for our entire class when i say
that it's definitely been a great
opportunity to take on this issue i know
we've learned a ton this semester
looking forward to sharing that with you
this evening um it's always important
and very um
enriching as a student to take on events
that um and topics that have real impact
in the community and are real events so
i hope that that comes across tonight
and uh let's get started so tonight
we're going to present
our findings about the cuyahoga inlet
dredge materials and opportunities for
beneficial reuse and starting off
tonight is rebecca montrose
okay
hi thanks again for coming everybody
start
um
i've been informed this is the
restoration ecology class of fall 2011.
here we are on a field trip that we took
down to the chesapeake bay in maryland
this fall
happy bunch
the goals of tonight's presentation is
to summarize some findings from our
class
provide the community with some
information pertinent to the dredging
project
and
sort of an unexpected twist has been
to add to the body of knowledge related
to this aquatic aquatic invasive plant
hydrilla verticillata
and so i'm going to be introducing the
project
then we'll be talking about the
watershed and history um
looking at the
properties of the dredge material itself
some studies that we did regarding the
release of methane gas
more information about hydrilla and then
some reference sites that we've visited
and looked at and some alternatives that
we've been
coming up with
so as many of you are
probably aware it's
landscape in our region um
is defined by
a long
process of accretion of sediment and
deposition of material from retreating
glaciers
and you we're going to hear more about
that in the watershed section
um and also
the area at the south part of cayuga
lake
has also
historically been marshland and the
water would travel through
this marshy area before entering the
lake
this has been altered of course and
leaves us
where we are today with um
some more severe
flooding instances and
the need to
manage and maintain the inlet through
the process of dredging
um
this slide is just demonstrating um
the
flood control channel which was built
from 1962 to 1970
which was very important of course for
protecting our
west part of town and downtown area
but of
course creates another
maintenance question in terms of
dredging which is
on the table now
so this
again might seem quite obvious but um
sediment collects in the inlets from
various tributaries
as brian eden said it impedes water
recreation and navigability
um but it is also
affected
the
ecosystem health
and
removing the sediment increases our
ability to control floods
there has been deferred maintenance
in the past 30 years or so and
which leads to
need for quite drastic measures
brief run through of dredging process
the
dredge
is the machine itself which
does this operation there are hydraulic
dredges
which
vacuum suck the material out from the
bottom mixes it with water to create a
slurry
and there are mechanical dredges which
just physically scoop the material out
in our case most of the dredging will be
done with one of these hydraulic dredges
and then pumped
through pipes to the southwest park
in the cascadilla creek area some of it
may be done with mechanical dredge
and that is only the first part of the
process secondly the
material is dewatered
for six months to a year
and
extensive time resources and land are
required for this process
and finally what we've been starting to
think about in this class is
a third step which is to
move or reuse this material in
a way that's beneficial to the community
one example that people are familiar
with perhaps is the 1999 lake source
cooling dredging study
for which 3 000 cubic yards of material
was removed
and again you can see this three in this
case four step process
of dredging
de-watering
and
brought in this case to a disposal site
in dryden which we visited with the
class and have done some analysis on the
material there
and again those are other dredging uh
just to
hit home that uh this has
is a long-standing tradition in the
community it's um
inevitable and necessary
part of
living in this area
which brings us to the current plan for
dredging of the cuba inlet these are
some of the
project partners that we've
outlined here
so
as you can see here the environmental
impact statement has just been released
on this project and we encourage
everyone to check that out if you go
dredging.com and
attend the hearing public hearing on
december 12th at city hall
so
our presentation is going to talk about
the qualities of this dredge material
and
speak to this larger question of how the
material could or will be used and the
numbers that we've been working with
have been within a range but the maximum
that we are operating under the
assumption is that we could have 660 000
cubic yards
which is
significant
and the current plan um as i mentioned
would be to bring this material to a
site
behind the parking lot
by of lowe's
south southwest park
which is about 20 acres
just
sort of some imagery
660 000 cubic yards of this material
would fill 25 000 dump trucks which
lined up would take you scrampin
um
and in our case the material will be
pumped as a slurry to the site but
eventually when it's moved it will be
taken in trucks and so the carbon
footprint is also a concern of course
this is a lot of
movement a lot of transit
um
this graphic is also just
sort of get point across that um
this is
a lot of dredge material this is on
the football field at cornell
and
then
really important to our project is
analyzing this aquatic invasive plant
which is
now
been found extensively in the south
edge of the park
and
the inlet as you may know was closed to
boat traffic in september and then in
october
it was treated
and
we've been looking at
some options
for
how we can
conscientiously
continue with the dredging project
without
exacerbating this problem
um just as a general framework for our
class we've
always been thinking about
a three
approaches to restoration ecology
and this again as as brian eden
mentioned
many people think of ecosystem services
natural processes that are typically
defined as beneficial to human use but
ecosystem function the
the processes of a healthy ecosystem
in their own right are
very important as well as habitat
restoration
so thinking about these as habitats for
plant and animal species
and now i'm going to
turn it over to matthew gonzalez
thanks rebecca
as we all know you know the the inlet
itself is the focus of the project and
the dredging operations but
understanding the hydrologic and the
geologic settings around it you need to
take a step back in this case a much
larger step back and understand the
watershed processes at play
a watershed
has a lot of different components at
different scales you can see here this
is the uga lake
and the two reservoirs in six mile creek
just another image of of the 60-foot dam
but also within our our gorges and our
channel systems are the sediments
themselves either
uh base sediments in the
bottom of the channel or the walls of
the the gorges themselves
in our case we have four sub-watersheds
that are contributing to the
southern kiego lake inlet complex
kiuget inlet itself is the largest and
that includes the area that drains from
treeman state park
watermilk creek is the smallest in area
and includes buttermilk falls state park
six mile creek
watershed is the largest that includes
the city's drinking supply
and cascadilla creek
is the second smallest in area
both cascadilla creek and six mile creek
have some channelized portions through
downtown and just for reference
cascadilla creek is the
creek that outlets right at the farmer's
market
so understanding whether water is coming
the other question could be where's the
sediment coming
and
as we rebecca alluded to previously we
have this geologic history and this
geologic
legacy
of erosion and sedimentation that is
obviously something that's likely out of
our hands
another historical legacy that
contemporary
times
must be aware of and
have to deal with is this idea of legacy
sediments which is usually the result of
human land use practices
generally attributed to
clearing fields for agricultural
purposes
removing
forest cover
which then disrupts the soil and all the
other agricultural practices of tilling
the soil
it stirs up the the soil um
increasing erosion erosion upland of a
flood plain and then bringing that
soil which would generally be held by
the forest cover
in those upland settings
but once in the floodplain it has the
potential to obviously get into the
flood
the streams and the channels and the
different contributors
throughout a hydrologic
system
it's not always necessarily coming
rushing down through our gorges and
channels but it's obviously increased
the amount of sediment within
or i would say aggravated the natural
geologic erosion and added a little bit
extra to the sedimentation process
uh just again to talk about legacy
sediments
we have a study that discusses 200 years
of forest cover changes in our region
you can see here
with a baseline at 1970 of of say 100
in that just about 100 just over 100
year period which we would call the
period of legacy sediment development
you have this removal
of a lot of the forest cover in the area
which then aggravates the erosion and
contributes to the
sedimentation within the streams and
ultimately the lake system which is an
accreting system
um just to again demonstrate where
the erosion the where the sediment is
coming from
uh
our class went out
just after the storms irene and lee and
observed over on banks road up six mile
creek a large washout of the road
if you were to look at an aerial image
of this
previous to the event
the stream channel bank is probably
about 40 to 50 feet
more
into the stream itself so
you have these these large rain events
which with the geology of our area
is is going to erode and normally does
erode and that's the geologic legacy
that we're
dealing with
so it's understanding that we're
operating within an accreting system
um
both aggravated slightly by human
activity but mostly this geological
processes
a study done in the early 2000s by the
inter-municipal organization
i believe it's called the kiko lake
inter-municipal watershed organization
looked at these sub-water actually
looked at the entire kegel lake basin
and i focused in down at the south end
of the lake for our purposes but they
categorized the different sub-watersheds
looking at their erosive capacities
and this actually corresponds with
another
model that was generated by
some environmental engineers at cornell
in the late 80s looking at
trying to quantify non-point sources of
pollutants within the system and
sediment itself is a non-point pollutant
and their numbers as you can see here
kyuuga inlet was categorized as very
severe
this red color
corresponds with the model itself
and these numbers are not kilograms per
hectare per year a number which will
come up again
towards the end of my section
we've taken we've been given this
information actually a lot of common
knowledge was saying that the
sedimentation is is this
in-stream erosion and there's probably
nothing you can really do about it we
tried to conduct one more study just to
look at landslide susceptibility
adapting a u.s geological survey in a
new york state geological survey
model for landslide susceptibility using
various soil components and slopes
getting an idea of areas that are
potentially
more likely to have some sort of
landslide
actually more accurately it's called a
mass wasting event
as demonstrated probably by that the
previous image of the road outwash
as would be expected a lot of our severe
our areas of of high hazard art
incised gorges throughout the hydrologic
system but susceptibility obviously
doesn't
necessarily mean that there is erosion
thinking back again about that comment
concerning legacy sediments and the
period of deforestation
like much of upstate new york
the southern kegel lake area has
experienced reforestation within the
last half century
with estimates that it's about 55 to 60
percent of that original baseline value
so even though we may have some areas
that are susceptible per se
it doesn't always equate to
contributions to this
erosion and sedimentation process
lastly what does this all actually mean
we had those model numbers which
showed the contributions on a
kilogram per hectare per year on the
the four sub watersheds we have this
number
possibly 660 to 670 000
cubic yards of dredged material that
they're considering
necessary for the project
and we have this understanding of some
sort of mass balance of sedimentation as
a continuous natural process versus us
trying to remove it and extract it so
this inverses out over time really
becomes a maintenance issue and a
maintenance regime
and having an understanding of the
inputs and outputs
obviously this potential contribution
is not
all going to be deposited within the
inlet system you can see here in this
image of a 1993 storm a large sediment
plume
uh actually reaching the lake the lake
is an accreting system this is the
natural flow for sediments towards the
north end of the lake
but knowing the ins and outs and
considering some sort of balance over
time is really
the bigger question we have this this
issue of deferred maintenance
for example if southwest park can only
handle 80 000 cubic yards per year
and we're removing
you know 80 000 per year of the 670 000
and we have this some
number some volume of sedimentation
within the inlet
you're not necessarily having this net
value of 80 000 each year um
that's that shouldn't be discouraging
though because
again
the lake itself is an accreting system
it's a natural process
partly aggravated by these legacy
sediments
but
something a motto that our class has
tried to adopt is
not calling dredge material spoils which
is sort of the general consensus but
this erosive
these erosive forces generating the
sediments this is parent material
soil in the making perhaps and it is an
opportunity knowing these ins and outs
for beneficial reuses and having an
actual long-term management and then
sorry long-term maintenance being the
dredging and then a management routine
which is the use of the dredge dredged
material for some purpose thereafter but
obviously before you can do anything
with the materials you have to know it's
biologic
physical and chemical compositions and
that's what the next section will
discuss hayden
thank you matt
so as matt said we are dealing with a
lot of dredged material um
being removed during this process um
so we took
a few samples from a couple different
sites originally we were planning on
using doing all the tests on the cayuga
inlet but as many of you know there's an
invasive invasion of hydrilla so we were
unable to get our boats out on the inlet
so we chose the next best thing which is
the six mile creek reservoir and we
chose this because assumably these are
the sediments that will be making their
way down to the inlet
so we had three different
transects that we took it was kind of
left center and right
and we chose a few choice samples from
these
steps that we took
and we were trying to find out
what are the characteristics of the
dredge material and
can this material sustain plant life
because if we found that it could
sustain plant life it kind of opens up a
whole new world of opportunities for us
to use this material in another way
rather than
just putting it on a site such as this
so this is the
another sample site that we had and it
was the uh
the
judge material disposal site for the
lake source cooling that cornell
conducted and we again had we took
samples from the non-dredged material
which is actually over here where the
cornell had not dumped any dredge and
took samples from where they had dumped
the dredge material over here
and this
gave us an opportunity to see
whether or not there are persistent
long-term effects and differences in
soil characteristics of dredge material
or
where you find your typical field around
uh hopkins county
one of the ways that we measured this
was to
take
rare rarefaction curves of plant
speciation so we started off by counting
the number of species that we found here
and we would make the
area that we were counting bigger and
bigger and we would count the number of
new species that we found
and
what we found was that
as you as your area as your area got
bigger the rate of finding new species
actually decreased so you're still
finding a lot of new species but less
and less as you got larger what we found
actually was that in the dredge material
which is in red you have
a higher number of different species
than in the non-dredged material
and upon further examination we found
that
the two sites only shared 52 percent of
the same species so they're actually
very different species growing in these
sites that are enclosed in vicinity so
here are the similar species and all the
ones in red are invasive or non-native
plant species
so these
in the old in the old field site these
are plants that are growing there and in
the sediment soil these are either
plants that had just found their way in
there or were actually
residents in the seed bank
from whenever they had deposited on the
bottom of cage lake and were then
introduced into the site so that could
explain why there's so many different
plant species or it could just be that
fact that there's very
the soil or the soils are consistent of
very different things
this is just a couple pictures of us
doing the actual sampling we use an
ekman dredge and here to
collect our samples in the cargo inlet
in the reservoir
and that's us in the lab
so we used the cornell nutrient analysis
lab and conducted the soil health test
which is available to the public
we had a lot of help from bob
schindlebeck and everyone else in the
health lab
and we tested the physical biological
and chemical natures of the dredge
material to kind of figure out what is
the stuff made of
and what what can we really do with it
and here we have the the results for the
nutrients in the dredge material and we
found that in the reservoir the six six
mile creek reservoir the aggregate
stability was actually much lower than
the control site or the dredge side so
it means if we were to use it for
something we would have to
either mix it with organic matter or
something else to make this stuff kind
of stick together more because as of now
it's kind of like a
kind of goop if you put on the ground so
that wouldn't work very well and if we
were to dispose that
anywhere it would kind of
make its way back in the inlet which
would defeat the purpose of the project
the organic matter this is one of our
surprise findings the kind of consensus
before this project was that we would
have zero organic matter they thought it
was just kind of like a clay soil with
nothing else in it
it's actually at two percent which is
fairly high you want to be at around
five percent for a very usable soil and
the control site was only about 6.4 so
we actually found a decent amount of
organic matter the ph was a little bit
higher than the control site but that
actually helped will help to
stabilize some of the other
nutrients that we have very high rates
of so
in the background you can see this is
kind of a
ph scale on the bottom and as you move
up the scale some of these nutrients
it's harder for plants to take them up
so one of them is iron right here and as
you can see we have much higher rates of
iron
in the field or in the reservoir as the
control side so iron
manganese zinc and aluminum
their uptake by plants is all inhibited
by a high ph so even though we have high
levels of these nutrients in the
sediment that we collected from the
reservoir their uptake is actually
buffered by the fact that we have a
higher ph and also as you can see we
have
kind of ridiculous numbers of
rates of calcium in here and magnesium
magnesium about double calcium is like
100 times or something
um but calc magnesium if it's if it's
found in this high rate could actually
be
harmful to plants but calcium acts as a
buffer to prevent the uptake of
magnesium into plants and both them are
necessary nutrients for plants but the
fact that you have such high rates of
both actually kind of stabilizes the
soil which means that it still could be
a usable
soil
so that actually it was interesting to
find that they all kind of balance each
other out even though we have very funky
numbers it's still a
possibly very usable soil another thing
that we found are what we expected was
that this would be very clay very fine
material that there wouldn't be much
else in there that would just be a very
a solid clay mixture but we actually
found that we more toward a silt loam
which is much better so it makes it
usable for a lot of other things
so as you can see the inlet
is a
yeah it's a sandy loam
the reservoir was a silt loam the dredge
material on the site was a loam and the
non-dredge was the silt bomb so actually
the non-dredged material was actually
more silty clay than the
um
than what we found in the inlet
ecologic had done a test to look for
rates of copper lead pahs and pcbs in
the inlet
and what they found was that most of the
samples they took fell within the class
a soil classification however you had
some hot spots which are here here and
here out of all the red
sample sites and what they found is that
there you had higher levels of lead
copper
only two class b ph is a one class b pcb
um
and this
however if we were to mix
this uh material with some sort of
organic matter to increase the volume
that would um dilute the amount of
metals we have in the soil which would
actually could make it approach a class
a
um
and these hot spots would then also be
mixed in with all these other areas so
that would also act to dilute
the hot spots and make them more toward
class a and if you use
organic material and mix it in with
there it actually
will bind with a lot of these metals and
make it biologically unavailable so that
was a very
even though you do have some high
numbers there's a very real possibility
being able to ameliorate this material
and make it very usable
so the lessons that we learned from the
soil tests
the nutrients found in the dredge
material are high in some cases but
self-stabilizing
it has low organic matter which is
better than what we thought which is
going to be none and it also has high ph
levels which act also to stabilize some
of these nutrients the sediment is not
clay but is in fact a sandy loam
and the dredge material does have the
ability to sustain plant life
um also the aggregate stability of the
dredge was kind of the most concerning
thing we found
um so it could be hard to use it as a
structural material but
there are many ways that we could
improve this and make it usable for many
different things so now i will hand this
off to nadia and she will
talk about the methane analysis that we
did
so in addition to the physical
properties of the sort of the dredge
material we were interested in some of
the biological properties
and
one of these
is the microbial community soils and
sediments in general are home to a
diverse microbial community
in anaerobic or low oxygen environments
microbial communities are dominated by
methane producing bacteria which consume
organic matter such as dead leaves
and respire ch4
and
key to this project dredging anaerobic
inlet sediments could release methane
that was produced by these bacteria
there could be an initial release
of the methane that was already in the
sediments
and if anaerobic conditions persisted
those bacteria might continue to produce
methane during dewatering
so to figure out how much oh why do we
care about this well we care about this
because as you've probably heard from
the fracking debate
um
methane is a greenhouse gas it's one of
the most significant greenhouse gases
after carbon dioxide
um
and
most anthropogenic methane comes from
agriculture and other changes in land
use
so if we can if methane production is
significant that would increase the
carbon footprint of this project
so to find out how much
methane might be produced
when we finally did make it out onto the
inlet we collected some samples
we were
we were aiming for a sample on a number
of transects
from
on the east west east and west banks and
the center of the channel so samples
here
samples here there
and there
the lake is this way
when we got back to the lab
we evacuated the oxygen in the jars that
we collected these samples in
to create an anaerobic environment and
then measured the methane concentration
over a period of approximately a month
so about every
every week to every half week we would
draw off a sample of the methane and um
and run it through a gas chromatograph
to see how much methane had been
produced
so here are the samples that um
showed appreciable methane production
most of them were on were from samples
taken from the banks
so numbers ranged from
in the hundreds to
uh from in the 100
micromoles to
about 3500 micromoles
and you can see
these are starting to taper off these
are starting to taper off
as are these this one already peaked
only this one is still going up
so
what this indicates is that um
what this indicates
is that methane production
continues for about
two weeks before it starts to run out of
food in some samples but in possibly
high carbon
sediments
methane production might continue and
possibly at relatively high levels
these are the samples all the samples
from the center of channels which is
where most of the dreading would take
place and it's good news
because most of them
produce very little methane it's only a
single hotspot
5c
that produced
more
methane and that hot spot
is right here near the buffalo street
bridge
one thing that might be contributing to
this
is the forested
area
upstream right here
where overhanging vegetation drops
organic carbon into the water where it
is then incorporated into the sediment
providing food for
methanogenic bacteria
and most of the low
most of the
low activity that
samples
were in the flood control channel and
getting down into the inlet
now how much methane does this sum up to
over the whole project
um
if we go with a lower dredging number
and assume the highest methane
production that we saw
it sums to about 4 500 kilograms of
methane which is about equal to the
production of 45 cows in one year
if we go with a lower number that we saw
in the
in the flood control channel and the
inlet itself
that's just one cow over the whole
project
if we go with
the higher
with the higher dredge volume which is
also the more likely dredge volume
and the
highest methane production
you get a methane output equivalent to
303 cows
in one year
or
about 30 000 kilograms
and
for the lower
methane production that's seven cows
so
what options for mitigation might we
consider incorporating into the plan for
dredging and dewatering
one option would be to promote
oxygenated conditions during the water
dewatering to hasten the transition from
an anaerobic or siege for producing to
an aerobic or
co2 producing uh microbial community
so
one way to do that would be to have a
thin sediment layer rather than a very
thick one because oxygen gets into
sediment through diffusion
so
down here very little because the oxygen
is in the water up here
um
it
you'll have higher oxygen concentration
in the sediment up here and much much
lower concentration in the sediment down
here so if you just have this layer of
sediment you'll have
higher oxygen concentrations
um the other option would be to
to artificially promote the um
to artificially deepen the depth at
which oxygen can penetrate
either by mixing it in some way or by
having channels that carry the oxygen
downwards
and you could do that you could do
either of those things
through a mechanical means physically
mixing it
or through biological means like having
worms which produce burrows
and worms or roots that sort of thing
however this would do nothing about the
initial release of methane when you
brought the sediment up
from the bottom of the inlet
one option which would which would do
something about that but wouldn't
prevent methane release in the future is
methane capture
this has been done on landfills and a
variety of biological composting
facilities
um
the idea is that
you you use the methane as a resource
capture it and then burn it for fuel and
that's not as bad as just releasing the
methane directly because methane is a
more protein greenhouse gas than carbon
dioxide
because
the
amount of methane released by our dredge
material is
relatively low even over the whole scale
of the project this probably is not
economically viable
a third option
might just be to do nothing
when you consider the whole time scale
of the project if it were spread out
over say 10 years in the worst case
that's like having a herd of 30 cows for
10 years
it's
while our well our survey of methane
production in the inlet was pretty
rudimentary and further studies would be
necessary
doing nothing and maybe
buying some carbon offsets or something
like that could be a viable option
especially because this there are
probably far more important problems to
solve on this project which peter is
going to talk about
thank you nadia
so
i'm sure most of us if not all of us
have seen the hydraulic that have
inhibited the
cargo inlet area and
it's really noticeable in areas like the
farmers market
so
i'll be introducing to you tonight
what that drill exactly is what its
impacts and conditions in ithaca right
now are and then i'll introduce and
discuss
base some basic experiments that we
carried out with hydrilla desiccation
and then i'll talk a little bit more
about potential management plans and
management methods for the hydrilla as
it relates to
our dredging project
if you look at the map here it shows the
present condition of hydrolyzed the mess
a little bit old it was in august 29
2011
and
you can see the
white purple rings here these are areas
of dense hydrilla
infestations and the purple circles show
rooted fragments that are present in the
area but are haven't taken really into a
population yet now they have spread out
a little bit and there are more
hydraulic in the upper regions of the
internet as well
now
so you can really see that it's focused
along the inlet area and much of the
invested area of hydrilla coincides with
the dredging area as well especially
areas like cascadilla creek here
is areas is an area that the city is in
charge of dredging so separate
management plans for hydrilla and
dredging that the city comes up might be
a viable option to consider as well
some literature suggests that increased
water turbidity
can potentially decrease hydrilla
population the basic concept is that
with less light hydrilla will not be
able to grow as much
now if we take a look at some of the
light extinction curves that we carried
uh looked at using seki disks in the
inlet area it shows that at water depths
of basically three or four feet deep
the
light intensity will go down so low that
it will basically reach zero what this
number basically means is we have
something called the light compensation
point
and the light compensation point is a
point at which aquatic species
respiration and photosynthesis rates
will equal each other so they will be
able to reproduce once
they hit the certain light compensation
point with hydrilla the light
compensation point is 15 micro moles per
meter square per second and as you can
see basically at three and four feet
deep you have
the light compensation points being
reached it's with the exception of the
cascadella creek road docks
but if you go back to the maps
you still have areas of hydrilla
infestation despite such turbid waters
so we know that
light infiltration
may prohibit growth but it won't be able
to completely remove the hydrilla from
from growing in these areas
we carried out some basic
experimentations with hydrilla and the
purpose of the experiment was to see
whether hydrilla would be able to
survive the drying of the dredged
materials and whether they would still
grow after being dried up it's important
because knowing whether or not they dry
out and whether they die out it can
limit what can be done with the dredged
material and we can determine if
treating for hydrilla in the dredge
material would be actually necessary
so desiccation is basically the
dehydration of an organism and we just
looked at how they would dry out over
the over time periods and certain given
conditions we dried out stem fragments
the cheerions and tubers of hydrilla
when we looked at stem fragments of
hydrilla we looked at different
conditions that it might be buried in or
incorporated into the dredge material so
we looked at different uh viable lengths
of fragments which are five nose and
tendons we looked at different depths
and we looked at different conditions at
which in which it might be buried so
whether it was completely buried or
halfway sparing
now we dried the uh sediment out for a
week and then we sift out the fragments
and re-water them to see whether they
will show signs of vitality
the results that we got were
unfortunately we were i mean we're
hoping for a result that would basically
wipe out the hydrilla because literature
did suggest that hydrilla dries out
rather quickly and they die out however
if you look at this you can basically
see that in all conditions of any type
of treatment nodes or depth
except for hydrilla that were attached
at the surface and completely exposed to
the atmosphere we had
some of these samples survive and since
we're looking at extinction of hydrilla
in these areas when we treat them this
shows that we can't rely on just
dehydrating the material and hoping that
hydrilla will go away so we this shows
that some other form of treatment will
have have to
be applied together with desiccation
and another thing that we wanted to note
was that
when hydrilla was dried we took stem
fragments that were in single lines so
we didn't have these growths to the side
and
however when we re-watered them and they
started growing cheerions and then some
new growth started coming out to the
side and this might be a potential
stress response where the hydrilla
shows
retains basic biological functions so
that they can survive in harsh
conditions
and then when they meet more favorable
conditions like a new water body that
they can grow in they might start
growing again so once again this is
important to realize because we know
that if we try to have the dredge
material come in contact with any water
bodies without properly treating for the
hydrilla we will have new growths coming
in
a similar experiment was carried out
with curiosity we didn't look at the
relationship to sediment drying but we
looked at different times of drying with
cherions cheerions are
mentoring buds that
are basically reproductive bodies for
hydrilla and
what we did was we looked at free
floating turians and triangles attached
to short stems and looked at how they
would dry out and re-water
and what happened with the turians was
none of the creons actually grew any
more than its original states after
uh dehydrating and re-watering however
they did retain shake they did contain
coloration so they looked like it looked
like a lot of them were actually
surviving the drying conditions so we
know that not all existing triangles
will sprout after drying but it's also
important to note that some of them will
survive
and something that should be noted with
the dredging project is that hydrilla
monoacious hydrilla in the ithaca area
will sprout churions during
late august to
october and this was what was observed
this year so any kind of dredging
projects that involves the spread of
materials we'll have to make sure that
it doesn't coincide with this time so
that we can prevent hydrilla spreading
we only found one tuber in three
20-meter buckets of sediment and this
was the amount of sediment that we
collected for the
actual experiment
now
in some sense it might be a good
suggestion that there might not be that
many tubers growing so it might have
less potential for spreading but at the
same time we dried this
tuber out for a week along with the
fragments
and yet when we rehydrated it it
sprouted perfectly fine on its own and
it shows that
drying can actually induce growth in
tubers because they can survive
long-term times of drying periods and
since our goal here is complete removal
of hydrilla from the
materials
this might not be such a desirable
condition for us at the present
situation
so if we do need to remove hydrilla from
the dredge material what would what
would we actually need to do
if the dredge material is distributed
over multiple locations like roadside
fields the possibility of hydrilla
spreading actually increases so we have
to make sure that the dredge disposal is
local and contained so that we can
control the hydrilla and make sure it
doesn't spread any further and to ensure
that proper control we require a
monitoring management plan where we
look over the dredge material and
continuously check for hydrilla growth
over time and then if the hydrilla do
grow back we'll have to carry out proper
treatments as the situation requires and
then repeat the process of monitoring
and treatment
one potential stretch management method
that uh the alternative section after
this will
treat a little bit more in depth is the
division of dredge material into
separate cells for detailed control and
dehydration so if we have different
cells of dredge material spread out over
a given location then we can look at the
area we can monitor it and we can make
sure that any hydrilla that comes up can
be properly removed
there are multiple ways of treating
hydrilla including
physical removal desiccation chemical
treatments and whatnot but
we wanted to look at primarily potential
treatment methods that we could uh
incorporate into the dredging material
project
so one method is looking at physical
removal in this case we're looking at
aquatic removal where the diver in the
picture is using suction dredges to suck
up hydrilla from the soil and
or using rakes to collect hydrilla and
basically remove the adrenal physically
physical removals are good because they
can be target specific we can go after
the hydrilla as we monitor them and as
we see them and we can combine this with
the monitoring process but
given that the upper limits of dredging
right now might be 670 000 cubic yards
this is extensive manual labor and it
requires a lot of time and it just might
not be cost effective
another method desiccation was the
method that we looked at but and like we
showed it doesn't require much manpower
it's basically letting the material dry
out so that the hydraulic can dry out
and die as well
but once again it can reduce the
hydraulic count but it can't eradicate
the hydrilla count so
it's difficult to confirm removal and it
will really be dependent on soil water
content
two more methods that we thought of
looking at were chemical treatment and
solarization now we
the hydrilla in the inlet area have been
sprayed with apothel k
and
they have been we have tried the city
has tried to remove the hydrilla
permanently using alcohol 4k
unfortunately there's signs showing that
hydraulic right now is coming back after
the chemical treatment so it's it once
again shows how difficult it is to
properly spray the entire area and once
again demonstrates how important it is
to have a controllable area that we can
properly spray under given conditions
so
spraying for example if we were drying
out the
dredged material in a terrestrial system
we could spread rock spray roundup in
the entire area and make sure that
everything in the area dies out and then
have to round up dissipate so that we
can use the soil for other methods other
means it's very efficient in control
settings but once again alpha 3 roundup
and all these other chemicals are two
are toxic so we do have to watch out for
potential toxicity and it requires a lot
of monitoring but once again monitoring
isn't a bad thing given that we want to
make sure that hydrilla is completely
gone and any kind of undesirable weeds
are gone from the area as well it might
be costly to spray the entire area given
once again how large the dredge material
is going to be
solarization isn't something that you
associate a lot with hydrilla because
hydrogen is an aquatic
vegetation and as any farmers might know
solarization is using
um
sheets of ponytail to basically
cook the soil beneath the solarized
areas but if given that if we dry out
the dredged material in a terrestrial
system
the hydrilla will also be in a
terrestrial environment so what we can
do is we can basically cover up the soil
with these sheets and
the optimal upper levels of hydrilla
of temperature for hydraulic
reproduction and survival is thought to
be at approximately around 35 degrees
centigrade with solarization if we
basically spread the sheets out and cook
the soil underneath it the temperatures
will go up to 60 degrees centigrade at
depths of two feet and 40 degrees
centigrade at depths of even 16 feet so
if you can spread the cells out nice and
thinly it can actually help with
aeration which goes back to methane
control
and control hydrilla and any other
undesirable weeds that might start
growing up in the area so we can
basically cook the hydrilla alive and
make sure that they completely die out
before we start using the soil for other
means
of course this will require lengthy
monitoring but given that the
dehydration process for dredge material
is going to require years as well this
could be a very nice combination of
methods to make sure that we don't have
hydrolyzed spreading around other
waterways
and with that i'll pass on the baton too
so i'm going to go over
a
variety of options including making some
sort of industrial product out of the
sediment
creating a um
some dry or upland sites
new land out of um out of the sediment
or using the sediment in the creation of
new wetland zones
so
first
there's the option of making a synthetic
soil
this is something that hayden had been
alluding to earlier
we do have a bit of a wacky uh nutrient
profile on this sediment but uh if we
end up combining it with some compost
which could be available from their
cayuga compost or possibly um ithaca
brewing we were thinking it since
budweiser has a similar operation
going to use up all of its beer
leftovers
we thought that you know we could have
about 9 000
tons of organic matter available to mix
in with the dredge material
which would then um
one dilute down any of the
oddities in the in the dredge material
and then create a sellable product as
well and depending on how much we dredge
you know there's different amounts of
product available for sale
um
other
options for products
include
brick making lightweight aggregates and
cement lock
there is a successful example of
brick making in that exists in germany
where they're using
dredge sediment as a partial replacement
for
the clay and fan content in bricks
and there's also been studies done
by georgia
georgia university to
completely replace the the sand and clay
content in bricks
so we could go into that business here
in ithaca
there's also the option of lightweight
aggregate oftentimes sediment can be
used in
cmus or concrete asphalt various
construction products
unfortunately um
we're not going to be producing quite
enough dredge material for that um the
the processing facilities to make that
are generally a lot bigger
maybe handling 10 to 100 times the
capacity
that we will actually have here in
ithaca
so then a third option would be cement
block
which
requires a much smaller facility to make
and actually it transforms dredged
material
into something analogous to portland
cement
so that could be a great product the
downside would be that we'd have to
build a factory for it so that would
probably
increase our costs quite a
bit um
now i'm going to talk about a few
different options for
either disposing or
that disposing of but moving the
material to
upland sites or the creation of new
dryland areas this
this project in dryden you've seen a
couple times already um
but we went out there with the class you
know it's left over from the light
source cooling project
and um basically what we found is you
know
it didn't turn out so bad 12 years later
um
you know things are things are growing
even where we you know had all of this
threads put down you know it just looks
like a field it's
maybe we're not getting anything
terribly useful out of it but things
could be worse
um
so you know one option that we thought
we could perhaps
take all of the the dredge sediment out
and redistribute it across the county
everyone can get their fair share and
put it out in their lawn or something
um
perhaps is
you know trying to get a bit more use
out of
the dredge and in a more practical
approach than trying to find a land of a
county
out in the county to put this on
it's a project out in buffalo new york
where they also had a canal that needed
to get dredged
also an industrial use corridor and um
they ended up uh creating a a controlled
um
disposal facility or confined
where they deposited all of the
dredge material
out in in a spot along the lake um and
created a
new
new bit of land which is now actually a
50-acre um
nature
uh nature preserve
um
so oh and then a similar project um was
done in cleveland ohio um same idea
um where they
you know created a
very controlled um
edge
on
on the site i slowly filled it in with
dredge material and again theirs project
is larger
i believe 88 acres
and now that is again also a nature
preserve
this is actually a pretty common
practice it turns out um
there are let me see 45 different
confined um
facilities throughout the great lakes
for um for using dredge material or for
containing it and controlling it um
so if this is something that we'd be
interested in doing in ithaca we'd be in
good company and there's a lot of
different example projects to look to
the way that they created
both the cleveland project and the
buffalo project
you can kind of see here
where they started by building a
perimeter out into the water
which then was slowly filled with
dredged sediment until you start
actually getting
some buildup of solid land
out into the lake
this has also happened much closer to
home right here in stuart park
used to be a wetland marsh area and you
know as rebecca talked about in the
beginning we've been having
dredging going on in in ithaca for
at least 100 years
and um
you know some of the the first
notes i've found of stewart park where
they were starting to reclaim the land
in 1911
and this kept going on throughout the
decades this plan in
1934 called for
adding another two to four layers of or
two to four feet um in a layer of
sediment um added across the park just
because it was um it was just too marshy
and swampy to be enjoyable for anyone so
um
you know now this may be seen as perhaps
a loss of wetlands but at the time this
was really um seen as a very good
beneficial project um
to keep out
all the you know undesirable flooding
and other problems that the city had
been having
pretty much same story goes for cass
park
the
dredging and building up of it got
started a little bit later and that
didn't really get finished until 1970s
after the flood control channel
had been uh cut out
so what that ends up leaving us with is
um ithaca's got a lot more dry land at
the at the southern tip of our lake than
a lot of our sister cities uh do or
some of them aren't cities but just our
sister finger lakes here
which um generally the natural state is
to have wetlands in the southern edge of
the lake before it starts sediment
carries on and moves
upstream
and exits out the north
alright next i'm going to talk about a
few options for
possibly creating a wetland type
situation
with the dredge material um
dredge material as has been said many
times tonight is already going into the
lake
um so this would be not
adding extra material to it but rather
just you know controlling
how it gets deposited within the lake
a few years ago there was a project
proposed
by rick manning and fred cowett
which just tried to look at taking the
dredge sediment and
getting some some ecological services
and benefits out of it
so what they proposed
you can see here is
a new wetland created right off the
western edge of stewart park
right up here
which would
slowly get built up over time we could
probably do this in a similar way as
with the cleveland and buffalo sites
so it would be a contained controlled
edge
and you know you could start providing
more habitat and
the other benefit could be actually
with a new findings on hydrilla
actually controlling
the potential spread of hydrilla by
keeping all of the sediment on site
rather than
spreading it out across the county
this could actually
be hindered by the hot off the press
draft environmental impact statement
that just came out uh where they're
trying to completely you know never have
any of this uh dredge sediment um
re-enter the lake be in for fear of uh
the hydrilla returning but i guess we as
a class felt that
keeping this all in one spot would make
a whole lot easier to manage than if we
start
you know either selling this off as
topsoil or in some other way
spread the
dredge material across the county the
state wherever
some um
some legal
issues and possible funding sources
actually
in 1992
there was a
law written saying that for navigate if
dredging needs to happen for
navigational purposes
um
then there could actually be um some
funding available for the creation of
new ecosystems
so
this could be pretty great if we
actually wanted to go after it
more research would have to be done
but
it appears that there could be up to
five million dollars available of
federal money for the creation of uh
wetland aquatic habitat of
the use of the stretch material
um and then this graphic that shows uh
the depletion of wetlands over time
so down in the green areas is where
wetlands were
furthest back in history and
as we go through yellow and orange
that's kind of what what is
left of them so it could be really great
actually to bring some of that habitat
back into the ethical area
poplar island is a project down in the
chesapeake bay that we went and visited
as a class
you know this is also actually very
similar to the the buffalo and cleveland
projects where
there had been an island here
in in 1847 it was a thousand acre island
and then by 1994 there was only four
acres of it left the whole thing it just
sort of disappeared but they needed to
do a dredging project to get into
baltimore harbor
and so they decided to rebuild the
island this has been a really giant
project
involving lots of different agencies on
all kinds of different
political levels but
it's been successful actually so it
again even as a both as uh how to get it
done uh physically and politically this
could be a good model for ithaca if we
chose to
um
try and keep our
our fridge sediment
within the water
uh
let's see
so yeah so after the uh the edge
containment was put up there
like was a cleveland site um they filled
in with uh with fred sediment and now
they've got some very viable wetlands
exist in there and all of these
animals that have been coming back to
the island on their own
that really they haven't been
introducing any of them on purpose but
it's it's looking pretty good as a
uh the viable new habitat
another group of people that we talked
to while down in maryland as a class
were from living shorelines
and uh what they worked on it was
trying to stop erosion from happening
right on the banks of this case the
chesapeake bay
but this could be a really helpful thing
for us in ithaca because especially
right along where the flood control
channel is
you know oftentimes there's really only
a thin strip maybe three feet of of
scruff between the water and in the lawn
so a lot of sediment and erosion can
happen that way
so what the people at living shorelines
did
actually i think some next slide
they will actually cut the
bank back so that it is a much more
gradual slope and then they're able to
plant it up with uh
with
wetland plants
and that keeps uh
more sediment and erosion from happening
which will hopefully hopefully keep our
problems from getting worse in the
future so that we don't have to be
dredging quite as often or quite as much
in the future as
we're looking at right now
one issue that has been brought up about
possibly putting
any sort of wetland project
like the the manning proposal in ithaca
is well we've got this
seasonal change in water level because
of the dam that's at the north end of
the lake
the water level actually changes by
three feet
so we looked at montezuma national
wildlife refuge up at the north end of
the lake
this is a 50 000 acre wetland preserve
and
that has a natural natural fluctuation
in water level and you know has been
doing just fine so uh we think it's you
know something that we could definitely
manage to get away with here um
and um and this actually also just
interestingly
was a uh reclaimed restored wetland as
well
it had been drained in 1910
when the canal was brought in and then
they restored it in 1937 with uh with
work from the ccc
um
and then um again another close to home
example uh this is watkins glen queen
catherine marsh
um this is actually a naturally
occurring finger la finger lakes wetland
um
right here in the in the light blue well
right up here is watkins glen and then
here in the light blue is uh where the
the glacial layer in the dark blue is
where
the existing queen catherine marsh
wetland is
this is a thousand acre wetland operated
by the new york
dec
and
this is still actually dredged from time
to time for navigation and flood control
purposes
it's a really great recreational
opportunity for people who live there
and um you know could be something
perhaps
ithaca could be envious of
um
so just to sum up um you know once we
get done with uh the actual dredging
process um or the whole you know that's
not it but
this isn't over um we can't really well
we could just
make this out of sight out of mind but
the dredge material really has the
potential um to be
uh of quite a bit of value and shouldn't
be considered a waste product
so for a few last final thoughts i'm
going to pass it back over to ben
thank you all for your patience it's uh
the
end of our presentation here
uh we definitely have quite a bit of
people to thank i think most the room is
on this list
but major the message is that we could
have done it without you all this work
and learning and
like to thank you for all the hours and
time that you put in all the late night
emails
respectfully returned
it's the end
and just as a closing note
we hope we provided you with a lot of
helpful information about this project
i hope you picked up on these key
messages that we've repeated throughout
we definitely have a lack of maintenance
going on here this isn't a problem
that's going away the last 50 years
there's been deferred
dredging in the lake and we're feeling
the consequences of it now
as well as the natural process this
isn't something that you know human
activity is necessarily created
but that is on top of an already
occurring process that would be there
whether or not we had taken away the
wetlands
in the early 1900s
that should be addressed as well
and i know there's a headache
on a lot of levels but it also provides
a lot of opportunities that we can take
on into the future
we've presented a lot of different
productive ways of managing the stretch
material
as well
this is a chance to efficiently plan for
the future this is 50 years we've
accumulated you know
660
000 cubic yards of dredge material on
this inlet
we can get rid of it once
where we're going to put it the next
time it's going to happen again and
again we need to take that into
consideration and then come together
because this is a unique opportunity to
bridge a lot of different agencies in
order to
increase the innovation methods so we'd
like to open up the floor now to
questions and we'll answer them the best
we can and
facilitate a discussion about this
nobody jumped to
you in the firmware
i'm a lake front owner and i'm aware
that we're not allowed to make new land
into the lake so did your project look
into any of the legalities with the
various agencies where you'd have to get
permission to make a new one definitely
yeah i mean matt could speak a little
bit more he did the reference about the
army corps the army corps
funding however just out at
base level um we know we've gotten a lot
of encouraging messages from speaking
with the army corps and given the
examples that we saw in cleveland and
buffalo
we definitely think it's look worth
looking into in terms of not just a
watershed uh habitat but also in terms
of the commerce you know there's there's
it's been done before you know it's it's
not something to
completely write off
in some of the earlier scoping documents
looking at alternatives various sites
including
deep water disposal or the creation of
new lines
as you're indicating
as far as we understood that the message
from the department of state was that
that's an alienation of
public
public trust i guess the waterway itself
we haven't found
the legislation that says that so it
sounds it sounds like policy
or
interpretation of policy
this army corps legislation this water
resources development act
section 204
beneficial reuse of judge material is
looking at
doing just that taking these systems
that are repeating systems there's
maintenance issues obviously if
navigability and flood control concerns
and
understanding that it is a process that
the lake itself i mean all those marshes
that we showed before you know those
were open open standing water previous
and
long geologic history obviously wetlands
themselves are creating systems
um
so i
we put the army corps legislation in
there as an opportunity
it may not actually be an option but it
seems something that
you know through a couple of phone calls
or emails or trying to get meetings
between these various agencies and
different levels of government could
potentially still
be an option
even though it was one of the
alternatives that was sort of
viewed as not feasible in the earlier
scoping documents we haven't really had
a chance to look at the draft
environments of that statement since it
came out just a few days ago when we
were
getting ready for tonight just a
follow-up comment about that is the 660
000 number that we've been throwing
around is a
from what we understand a army core
estimate of if you removed all the
sediment from the inlet that would be
the amount that would restore
restoring the original configuration
yes
ongoing projects um well
we still haven't finished the report
we're gonna put together next week
yes
be available online somewhere eventually
yeah definitely
the contact person for that is um brian
eden
yeah well i haven't talked to tom we
were you know planning to have it up
on some uh site but uh i'm not clear
exactly it was it's going to be a corn
outside or
be one of our sites
yeah i'm not sure either at this time
this is
the
we have to get it down the size so that
it's not 12 gigs
but
yeah there'll be copies of it around
there will be
dvds
of the
proposal and we'll probably give you 10
of those or something
i think your study is really good and a
fantastic job
for a class thank you uh but if you look
at the southern end of cuba lake we've
got another elephant
in
in the room and that is fall creek and
all the sediment that's coming up which
doesn't go into the inlet but goes
just in front of stuart park
and so
how long is it going to be before the
end of the lake is going to become a
wetland because of all that sediment
that's coming in as well
it may not
require the department of so and so
to legislate no you can't where you can
sure it's going to happen by itself
definitely i mean if that's the case
then aren't we
saying the next time we dredge well
we'll just add to what's already forming
there
that's
like you said we didn't look at fall
creek for just for that reason we had to
found our system in looking at the
project but though that earlier uh
manning proposal
was building up basically
you know
defining fall creek
as it exits uh through stewart park um
you know something were constructed
there like you said there's a lot of
sediment coming from fall creek and
wetland there would
probably trap some of that sediment as
well which
maybe has a maintenance issue in itself
but understanding that it is this
natural process and
having the opportunity to
the options of either just letting the
inlet itself accrete
versus letting
a little bit more out into the lake of
crete
i think the concern of
wetlands generating on their own is on a
time scale that
i don't know i can't really wrap my head
around that in terms of
us still worrying about boating activity
but
as a larger management regime and
maintenance issue
understanding the whole hydraulic
hydrologic process of sedimentation
including fall creek is probably
something that has to be considered
yes
i'm the manning of the oh
actually great no responsibility credit
for that um
it was really tom needed horn like the
mid 80s did the stewart park plan it was
kind of panned in the community um
and charlie troutman who's now the
director of the science and there's a
lot of studies of how
the sediment would be pushed further by
that finger
and kind of dispersed further out in the
lake
so i think there's a lot of
and i thought fred did a really nice job
of kind of designing that studio context
of what that
what that could look like and
i really do think it's a great
opportunity and it has i guess just
doesn't seem to be feasible according to
dec and or army corps current
regulations but
it doesn't seem to be a sensible
decision to make i think it's a i think
it is a real opportunity it's nice to
see it there
would be worth
fighting for but i'm not sure how
it's been tried a lot i think it hasn't
been successful but
through through the whole
ecological dredging
environmental impact process
there is a stewart park plan in the 80s
that i you may have seen and i have a
copy of it anyone's interested in the
studies that were done i think it's pre
pre-computers are kind of these manual
studies but
to see how the sediment would flow from
fall creek out into the lake and get
further away from depositing right in
the vicinity of stuart park
so it was an interesting
moment that
really fred kind of played out in the
context of the studios sure just two
points about that before the next
question um
if you looked at some of the earlier
imagery you see
you know
i don't know if you could follow the
point
there's the sediment plume is just it's
visibly coming from the inlet six mile
creek
uh
complex and not so much the fog in fall
creek coming along
the south of stuart park
hitting the breakwater and sort of like
you said
circulating around there it doesn't seem
to be
we didn't use it i didn't look at the
model numbers for segmentation coming
from the fall creek watershed because it
wasn't part of our system
but that's you know
the opportunities that this study has
looking at hydrilla alternatives and
considering some of these other methods
and things that are already out there
that could be used has a lot of
potential but also the second point you
said
uh you know you haven't spoken with
anyone from the state or these other
agencies
throughout our process we didn't we also
had didn't have a chance to speak with
people at dec or the department of state
but we spoke with
the gentleman from the army corps who
works
i believe in the buffalo region
mentality was encouraging he's the one
who informed us of this beneficial
re-use legislation so it seems like
the uh the earlier question i was trying
to answer is you know
it
it's a potential and it may just be a
matter of getting
more than one agency in a room at a time
but we didn't have that opportunity
just to reinforce a little bit of that i
i've confirmed from the thinking that
was
done in the 80s study in kiana
but it seems like it has been still
involved by this
you know
didn't i see in your presentation there
were four projects in the great lakes
the great lakes yes i mean
i just wanted to respond to an earlier
comment you know the reason that uh the
sediment from fall creek even though
it's not as significant as that from six
mile creek there's this uh
process called the coriolis effect you
know particles in suspension move
counterclockwise so the fall creek since
it doesn't have a does uh it moves very
close to the shore in that effect and
when the prevailing northwest winds it
pushes right into the shore if you've
gone by the maintenance building at
stuart park or by the large pavilion
they'll see large amounts of debris that
have been pushed in there
because of the prevailing winds and
they periodically have removed that but
the last time they removed so much that
they actually moved part of the
sediment
in the lake bed itself and we're fine
pretty significantly
i think this image kind of represents
that
you can see it when you're out there you
can i mean this is a flood condition
obviously you can see the water up over
the edge of the park here but
where that break water hits the water
just spins around
any other questions comments
um yes in the report um
i saw where
uh the part of the study said if you use
the dredge material and you
understand to make topsoil you can make
topsoil will allow them eventually
okay
and one of the low numbers of for x
pound of drug material you get 800
million dollars
is anybody doing that
is that like
so there's a corporation that does that
they're making all this you know making
800 million dollars
i don't think the number was quite 800
percent
i think there are i found an example of
a place in michigan
that does take um
kind of dredge material and kind of fill
and then mix it with compost and do sell
it as a usable product we don't know
exactly what the numbers would be based
on the kind of material that we get we
were just kind of trying to
give a ballpark range for what topsoil
sells for and with the numbers they were
getting i think the high end was like
two million total
um
and there's also issues with how much
cake we used
compost and cranial compost
to get just kind of a general number of
how much organic fat we have locally
and cayuga i think it would have been an
issue i think that town might have to
come with some agreement buying off
their compost or figuring out so the
numbers are a little iffy but there has
been precedence in the past of people
using a material that isn't quite ready
mixing with organic matter and
selling it as usable materials
yes um
i guess at full disclosure i work for
the city of ithaca
i have a question about your hydrilla
desiccation study
did you consider how long it would take
to
inactivate the tubers because that's the
real concern not the
vegetation well with the tubers seismic
factor we didn't have enough specimens
for a proper experiment right the other
issue was that we
were expecting the tubers to last for a
really long time
other literatures from florida where
they have diageous tubers under diabetes
hydrilla
and from carolina and these other areas
where they have monoasia's
hybrid
tubers have been shown to survive for
basically anywhere from two to five
years and
under dry conditions too so they can
basically regrow if they if they dry for
three four years and then they pull it
back in the water
then they'll grow up again so it's
something that we
wanted to talk about in more detail but
we just didn't have the
time over the semester so i i don't know
if you know this or not but the city did
draw together all the agencies and talk
about the dredging project in light of
hydrilla
and that is the major concern is how
it's going to add to the holding time
necessary for the material
so if your next class i guess or as
you're writing it up comes up with some
good ideas please let us know and my
follow-up comment um and help i guess is
that you will try and share this
information um with the city on the the
recent document that came out take
advantage of that public comment yeah
definitely we're planning on submitting
to the uh by the 16th yeah
in addition to the hydrilla survival
is there a viable seat bank in this
material
or is it just too anaerobic
i mean that was when we did the uh the
rare fashion curve for the dryden site
that was one they had very different
species in the dredge material and in
the old field we're not sure if what the
exact cause from that was there's
different rates of runoff in the direct
material it's made a different um it's
like a different type of soil
but there could be a seed bank
in the area
but that's we can't i don't think we
have enough information to answer
definitely on that but it's a distinct
possibility
but it would be
um siege from the general area because
where the
sediment is coming from
kind of like the surrounding banks from
the creeks that run up into the
watersheds so
um if the opportunity to create a
wetland and usually
didn't happen um you mentioned that all
this dredge material will be placed
behind lowe's
yeah that's the current um
that's the plan yeah there's a site back
there um what's that habitat like is it
like a
grassy area
we'll kind of talk about it but maybe if
we
you know trip on our toes you can
correct us it's just a holding area yeah
it can't stay there because of that
picture you have the football field
right yeah
so it wouldn't be possible to spread it
out and kind of like
that 20-acre site would be a staging
area for different processes of the
dewatering
ultimately their plan is to
confine it to a permanent eight acre
site for future
dredging maintenance
um and then
you know the the site the remaining 12
acres has potential for something else
but
that still doesn't answer you know
where's the once it's been the water
dewatered where's the the sediment
the dredge material
you're also talking about separating the
sand out
as part of the process okay spray it out
and the sand goes
out further or something so you end up
with
materials different types of materials
yeah so through that it's you know four
or five cells at different stages of the
process you can try to extract different
senses of clays
for different uses
the land area isn't going to be used to
create a sort of
nature preserve or a habitat because i
mean if you can grow
even invasives or non-native plants it
still comes with viable habitat for like
struggling sure yeah it's partly i mean
in the past it has been used as
a disposal area for
construction material
yeah there's the point also is that
there after that what next you know how
much space is there on the inlet to put
this and in the future where is it going
to go the next time sure yeah all right
i would just have that i think the
future of that site is quite uncertain
at the moment there is there was a lot
of planning that went on over the past
20 years it kind of led to the idea that
the
the uh the large portion of that site
would be developed eventually as
a identical residential
ideally sort of a new urbanist
eco-community kind of thing but
because it hadn't been ill because it
had been used as a uh as a
as a disposal site for coin filled by
the city and the drainage has been
changed quite a bit over time there's
actually a significant amount of
re-establishment of wetlands on the site
so
you know that are now jurisdictional for
uh army corps of engineers
so those wetlands you know like
disturbing those wetlands is
is
possible but it would be very difficult
to do for a variety of reasons and
probably not necessarily all that
desirable
and
basically the plants that were in place
are kind of
shot full of holes so it's not clear
what the future of that site would
ideally be
thanks
yes would you consider flood control
further up the creeks
meaning uh sort of in-channel
interventions
diversifying the channels and
marshland wetlands
sure settlement ponds
um
i mean an example of that is the the
silt pond just before the 60-foot dam is
intended to
do just that remove some of the still
tests to prevent clogging the dam which
actually is now in the process or soon
to be
dredged itself to increase capacity
because of the decision to keep the city
on its own water supply
um
i think one of the issues with that
is the understanding
the in-stream and the channel bank and
just the geology and the fact that it's
you know it's it's varying layers of
solid and fragile and trying to do some
sort of uh structural things
uh and altering the the gorgeous
themselves they're pretty incised when
they're not incised
meaning you know steep banks
below water flowing through
you have channelized portions through
downtown
i can't imagine there would be any
permission to do alterations with the
flood control channel itself under army
corps jurisdiction there's requirements
for
maintaining the lawn directly adjacent
to the
to the rip-rap embankment
we didn't we didn't look into that i'm
going to talk about above
landslide practices
okay
we're in the inlet creek uh we've got
the railroad which is the barrier
analyzes
accretion process further upstream now
we hadn't we didn't investigate
we did talk briefly about using home
depot and lowe's and wegmans as a site
for reinstating flood plain
around
runoff rates
are
pretty fast it doesn't take we didn't
show our infiltration studies here but
it doesn't take very much rain to get
run off
so
you know half an inch of rain we can
have the water come up and down in the
space of eight hours that's really
difficult
to deal with using physical
infrastructure unless you're
literally trying to turn it into the
lower mississippi or something so
we've kind of built ourselves into a
corner here by virtue of having
eliminated so much of our natural flood
plain in an area where the
where the velocities are slowing down
and their sediment does fall out so
our degrees of freedom are
here
the question built on that
since we have eliminated our flood plain
we have built all this up including our
sewage treatment plant down there
uh
any thought into using this material to
protect some of that
you know creating more berms around
these
uh so when these floods like the picture
hadn't been
ago
when they happen
our water our sewage treatment plant
isn't
six feet under water sure
the whole area is not underwater very
early on
i think i
broached that with tom and he reminded
me that that's even further
disconnecting us from
the floodplain
trying to create dikes and or levees and
obviously that's something that you know
you could do with the material but it
might exacerbate
the situation
also
is very low so if you're trying to build
up in any sort of berm
once water hit it just kind of slumber
in the drying process could that be
dealt with though if it were to stay dry
it almost forms like a concrete but once
you mix it with water then it kind of
so we really need more play
to both increase the aggregate stability
but more importantly from the standpoint
of building levees out of it we'd want
something that would
that would hold water you know literally
so something that would have a very low
hydraulic conductivity under saturated
conditions but that's
that's a that's a thought we did talk a
little bit about maybe raising the datum
of inlet islands six feet or so to
accommodate this new development that
everybody's pushing for
um
but you know there
are a number of alternatives that could
be considered but they have to be based
on
careful engineering studies and probably
modifying the material
i think we um well one more question and
then we're gonna have to wrap it up it's
gonna be time is your alternative
description did you
take a look at which alternatives might
be mutually exclusive or which could be
used in combination
um that's a good question because like
peter said looking at different areas of
the dredge material there's definitely
different you know in cascade creek
there's a lot more hydrilla maybe that
section should be managed on a different
basis maybe it should be zonal
and that's definitely open to
suggestions i mean we provided a healthy
amount of alternatives but which one is
most apt for which situation that's
definitely a discussion that could and
should happen
the alternatives are both spatial and
temporal you know you do one thing at
one time then you come and do another
thing potentially at another time it's
we're not going to dredge up 660 000
cubic yards in one year especially
considering the de-watering site is is
only capable of handling 80 000 cubic
yards so
um i mean one of the things that we
hoped we could do was present a lot of
alternative ideas thinking slightly
outside the box coming up with
you know this concept of maybe breaking
it up and
understanding that the dredge process
versus the clam shell versus the
hydraulic you're gonna have different
conditions um
just trying to reintroduce that into the
conversation perhaps and
basically raised a lot more questions
and hit as many problems with one
process as once you know layering one
like peter said might you know kill the
methane so how do you layer these
processes to create the biggest
effect
well i think the rate the current rate
the cities estimate is the most they
could possibly dredge in one season
would be 80 000 cubic yards i think
that's the number that we read
and not the hydraulics
not the hydraulic season so
yeah i don't know if that includes the
hydraulic season or not okay well i want
to thank
the students for coming out into the
community
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu